I shave my legs everyday.
It's seasonal.
I do not shave my legs.
I don't know why I shave my legs.
I guess it's just cuz that's what people do?
If I think someone I like is going to see my legs, then I'll shave my legs.
And I think it does feel better.
Honestly, I feel like I shave more for other women than for men.
Ow! No...
That just doesn't sound worth it.
My mother used to tell me that beauty is pain.
No that doesn't sound right... No.
If there's a chance my flesh is gonna get eaten, or have hairy legs... I'll just go with hairy legs.
I would be scared if I had this in my bathroom that I would be tired and put it on my hair.
I think it makes sense that women shave their legs because of marketing. Women do a lot of things because of marketing.
I think that's like the world that we live in.
And being aware of it, is important.
Not the way I do it. I'm an efficient shaver.  *laughter*
S*** who shaves their legs everyday?